Bella a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video allora Questo qui
è presente Ciao a tutti amici bisogna
fare questo video tra di noi che non è
una vita Voglio fare un video tra di noi
quindi ho detto beh facciamo un video da
noi oggi siamo qua per quello che mi
interessava fare avere un dialogo va
bene un dialogo Allora c'è stato un
periodo di questo un'intervista ok
questa più che intelligenza dialogo
un'intervista che faccio domande però
podcast molti dei ragazzi che stanno
guardando questo video sicuramente
vedono in me e in te quello che ti
tirano tutti ogni tre secondi quando ti
fermano infanzia ok E fino qua ci siamo
ma l'interazione tra me e lui è sempre
stata un po' strana e allora io volevo
chiederti Perché io nei tuoi confronti
ho avuto anche un po' di competizione
genuina però e quindi ti volevo chiedere
Tu come te la sei vissuta questa cioè mi
hai odiato c'è stato un punto che tu mi
avevi detto assolutamente mai una volta
mai detto una cosa però porca questa eh
Iniziamo prima con la cosa e poi e poi
dico tutto il resto una volta mi ha
fatto ruote che Ma tipo mezzo copiato un
video non mi ha citato e na cosa del
genere e io l'ho detto Poi ho chiesto
pure scusa perché ho usato un metro di
me modi Io purtroppo sono umano quindi
uso modi non è non ce l'avevo con lui
assolutamente Però una cosa c'è da dire
noi per tanto tempo siamo stati lui il
numero uno Io il numero 2 in Italia
questo possiamo dire perché i numeri
parlano non è che non è per vantaggio
negli anni 2016 2017 dal 2019 al 2000
2015 2017 Eh sì però poi abbiamo
iniziato poi praticamente insieme Io
forse ho iniziato poco prima di lui
questa è stata la nostra prima
interazione Vedi Siamo uguali i capelli
io me ne sono uguali i primi Eh guarda
eh Mamma mia sì c'era questa
competizione genuina però i fan non sono
i tuoi ma sono tutti i miei erano
convinti che io diassi te e te odiarsi
me cioè i miei fan erano dobbiamo
superare Favij io questa cosa non l'ho
mai detta considera Ok lui nel 2015 fu
la prima persona che mi fece gli auguri
per il milione di iscritti Ma va Tu sei
stato il primo sei stata la primissima
persona e tra l'altro mi ha scritto un
messaggio Bellissimo meraviglioso lo
possiamo dire se vuoi io ma io me lo
ricordo un cazzo perché veramente mi ha
colpito questo ha detto Complimenti per
il Mi ricordi il succo il messaggio
Complimenti per il milione di iscritti
eh Te lo meriti Sono contento anche che
sia tu perché oggi hanno raggiunto dopo
di te poi Il Milione dopo di me l'hai
fatto tu Esatto
primo a noi sono state il terzo Allora
iPantellas iPantellas tu hai il button
con la tua col tuo logo anche tu ce
l'hai no Il dato è un colloquio ce l'hai
solo te eh io c'ho quello che però
praticamente
E allora lo raccontiamo dopo il solo
racconto
Il messaggio è il primo a farmi gli
auguri È stato lui è stato Lorenzo e mi
ha scritto vabbè sono contentissimo Eh
se mai qualcuno in futuro mi dovesse
superare Sono contento che sarei tu
questo hai scritto
figo e oggi siamo arrivati qua per
quello volevo capire appunto come tutta
la fossi vissuta la vivevo bene a me non
avevo neanche la cosa di devo superarti
mentre il contrario di altri colleghi di
cui non farò nomi che era devo superare
Dexter Eh perché devo superare Favij Eh
perché devo superare i Mates molti
colleghi ci hanno questa cosa del devo
superare i tempi io non non ce l'ho mai
avuta perché poi comunque ti crea della
negatività al dover per forza No perché
devo fare ma ci sono
tanti colleghi che hanno questo metodo
di approccio Però spiegami sta cosa del
button che io ti ho scassato scusa Ah
bellissimo Allora il Golden button in
realtà non l'hai rotto te in realtà
perché ce lo consiglia ce l'ho
consegnato a Milano lui Per sbaglio ho
prese il mio Battle ed era rotto ed era
proprio il mio ha detto cavolo ha rotto
le palle
abbiamo fatto un sacco di discorsi
positivi Raccontami del di quella volta
in cui ti sei incazzato va bene va bene
quindi io mi ricordo sta scena a un
certo punto arriva lui ma era lo stesso
giorno in cui ti ho scassato il button
quindi era già incazzato
Ok Comunque vabbè io c'ho io purtroppo
non è che voglio essere aggressivo cioè
io i metodi da fa un po' da Romano
Infatti dopo gli ho chiesto pure scusa
te l'ho richieda ancora perché io per
scherzare ho detto dopo te devolina Gore
capito così tipo Tipo minacciandolo ma
non è non è non è che volevo minacciato
così mi giro io ho detto mi spiega una
cosa io va bene tutto va bene prende
ispirazione tutto eh io ho detto a me mi
dà fastidio perché questo video mi hai
fatto tipo la copertina uguale e il
video uguale le le foto uguale ma mi
vuoi citando che poi che video era non
mi ricordo manco ieri era una stronzata
di questa piccola cosa tanto io volevo
fa sempre un video volevo fare sempre
dei video con lui no però non gliel'ho
mai chiesto Ma no perché
perché volevo fa talmente una cosa cioè
non volevo fare un video con lui che
fosse stupido un video bello
censura me lo fa coi controcazzi
Ma allora tu ci hai avuto un periodo
buio molto buio Sì ho avuto mi ha
iniziato depressione e che mi Addolorata
poi due anni ero molto stressato Nel
senso che io stavo 12 ore davanti al
computer a lavorare Io mi alzavo pensavo
a YouTube lavoravo su YouTube per
YouTube andare a dormire e sognavo
YouTube La prassi di chi ha fatto questo
lavoro tutti i giorni tutti i video è
giusto sapere che anche se le cose ti
vanno bene a livello lavorativo e tutto
quanto non significa che tu non puoi
essere depresso cioè perché purtroppo ho
passato due anni molto brutti ho preso
dei farmaci Ovviamente i farmaci non è
che mi hanno aiutato con la creatività e
tutto quanto
e
quindi è stato un periodo molto brutto
per fortuna poi ne sono uscito e quando
sono uscito poi vabbè Mi sono anche
insomma fidanzato con la mia compagna
Valeria e che mi ha aiutato anche uscire
da dal periodaccio e una volta uscito io
c'avevo voglia di fare video perché
comunque c'ho voglia di rimettermi in
gioco però
ho voluto
prendermi tipo una vacanza dalla
depressione e quindi godermi poi quello
che non mi sono goduto quando stavo per
10 anni concentrano su YouTube perché
stavo sempre a casa Eh quindi godermi un
po' la vita i momenti intimi anche con
la mia compagna e
stare ritrovare la serenità che non ho
avuto per due anni E poi ora Insomma ho
tanti progetti tornerò anche su YouTube
con con varie cose quindi sono molto
positivo e finalmente felice Insomma di
aver ripreso in mano la mia vita Bene
bene
grazie per aver condiviso anche perché
comunque sono cose personali Vabbè dai
Comunque grazie di queste parole
dove alziamo un po' l'asticella
iscrivetevi al canale anche quello di
Dexter che tra un po' riparte faremo
cose incredibili anche insieme perché
appunto
funziona qualsiasi tasto benissimo
grazie ciao